[Music]
it is not necessary to say how hard the
country's economic condition is we have
to embark on a new program to go forward
we have to work together to do that
[Music]
[Music]
ranil vikramasingh has served as prime
minister to gotham pakistan was then
appointed acting president by gotabheraj
paksa there is no doubt that there is a
link to the rajapaksa family
[Music]
this is going against the calls and the
demands of the protesters and the public
so it will be very interesting to see
how the eighth president is able to move
forward when there's real anger towards
him and i don't know how he's going to
be able to govern in such a context
[Music]
one of the biggest things he would have
to do ranil vikrama singh as president
is to reach out to a cross section of
the public because he is not seen as a
legitimate popular leader so this is
going to be a challenge and if there
isn't stability in the country we are
likely to see further deepening of the
crisis so for sri lanka's own future i
hope we are able to get that stability
[Music]